hey guys how's it going today we are not
in my kitchen but we are making
something really exciting we're gonna be
doing a brother/sister bake off craft
off this is drew and Jonathan and I just
started YouTube pretty fun we did yeah I
just got brothers our channel and the
channel is solely taking on the sisters
everything we post is gonna be taking
you down this is okay and some other
stuff hello this feel much like my
normal look I got you hair looks okay
what good is all about Halloween I mean
we love Halloween I would literally
dress up year-round I kind of do but I
want to do some Helene challenges some
food and some crafting oh well I'm gonna
be making these little pumpkin cupcake
things and Jenna's gonna be making like
a little Frankenstein decorative tin can
I eat the contents of the tin you can we
are gonna make a haunted ghost load of
cheesecloth and then also some little
mummy cookies here half an hour right
okay that's good that's good half hour
on the clock go to your first cupcake
contributing alright here we you want to
take em all well thank you yes I don't
mind if I healthy kids
mmm-hmm you're supposed to cook this
before you eat it that's what I know
she's already closed mm-hmm no not good
Oh
best thing about myself and as your
sister organized oh not organized yeah
but I'm also know what organ yeah it
sheds on what it depends they have a
question what's your favorite Halloween
like movie or TV show or growing up
hocus-pocus all my goodness we actually
dressed up to focus focus when we were
younger it was a credible basically what
I'm doing is I'm taking a cheesecloth
I'm gonna harden it over a little form
here and then I'm gonna spray it as well
with hairspray and trying to get
hardened and then when I take the form
out from underneath that foam ball it
should stand up like it goes mm-hmm this
is really well everybody's going great
don't have 21 minutes oh my gosh I have
to actually bake cookies I'm just making
crafts I only think about crafts as you
can't eat it and so it's a little bitter
share you better share yeah
brothers and sisters they're gonna share
oh oh god I haven't used the hot glue
gun since like fourth grade I was making
crafts that fourth grade oh I've got a
big tub of glue that you would have and
there's always that kid in the class who
ate it that was me you did it well this
is that glue right here except for now
it's all added water it's all sticky
into my fingers ooh I don't know anyone
never eating glue but this one kid at
nap time in kindergarten took the
stuffing out of his sleeping bag and put
it up his nose and I had to call like
the ambulance had to come you're like
yes his name was Christopher Christopher
you Christopher
ruin naptime for everyone Christopher is
a pain I'm gonna add more cheesecloth I
gotta make this bigger it's really nice
craft favorite Halloween song
that's not oh that's a good song
yeah that's a - could you did you ever
practice the dance routine I tried it I
give up and then you know what I don't
know if you guys get a fair amount of
time to do all is just take your time we
just can't take they did you guys start
singing it well uh I pumpkin in my hair
[Music]
the hot glue gun is I'm having issues so
I'm just gonna help you with a hot glue
gun
yes my bum is toasty or should I put
this on his body so what is the balls oh
my gosh that's a mega bolt
I know it's look at this heavier than
the cane I know what I say we put it
towards the bottom here do we need to
drill through you're just gonna stick it
on or not the best I can drill all free
oh don't be silly
I mean if you have a drill handy I'm
gonna see if I have it real hindi okay
and people say you can't use drills huh
look at that see Frankenstein I think
credible I have to do a touch-up look at
that I'm actually using vodka as blue
for the advantage now I think that's
normal
totally normal three and a half minutes
I need eyeballs eyeballs what kind of
eye balls at a black hole time over here
over here eyeballs and start throwing
what I don't know I'm very careful just
run right attire wanted veil teeth this
is a gear that haunted bride from it was
it what was my Beetlejuice was it a I
think I missed that phone what what hold
on a second
you have never seen Beetlejuice I mean I
know who Betelgeuse is so we went three
times son should I finish it up the
Jonathan short one cookie did you eat
one cookie Popeye John intro to cookie
hold that up everybody hold up their
creations we have to what if our
creations didn't turn up is little look
good mine's just a little pumpkin is it
a Frank
you have to be frank and check with the
mullet yeah and you use the bottom of
the cupcakes tonight is something this
is what and I have a haunted spooky
ghost wondering why I did that's
actually really cool I did have five
ghosts zombie cookies what a blue-haired
spikey you took one of whoever that was
I find him do you want to let it fight I
always do the same for a highlighters
yeah give everyone a taste test this hmm
I'm gonna tell you guys this tastes like
give me give me a simple sample this is
a showgirl I can already tell you that
your cookies are tasty my zombies arm
just fell off yeah Jenna do you want to
try mine yeah go ahead you try mine
tastes like a cupcake I have a lot of
icing on it
oops and he just destroyed yours well
that's it I hope you guys learned Lots
because obviously were professional
chefs this tutorial it's not a tutorial
oh definitely really good not simple
bite a simple bite Oh am I take a second
simple bite nope I'm okay alright guys
that's it
thank you all so much for watching hope
you enjoy this happy Halloween
make sure you check out their Channel
that's not brothers check out channel
channel everybody anybody who knows us
knows we love Halloween and we have a
stash of hundreds if not thousands of
costumes we are here with the incredible
Jenna and Justine and your YouTube
channels we've got it's me Jenna E hi
Justine and we are the Scott brothers
and we have picked out costumes for each
other yes mm-hmm
do you want to see what I'm going to
make you wear